le césar du meilleur espoir masculin est
attribué à jean pascal zadi le premier a
triomphé dans cette catégorie pour un
film qu'il a réalisé et le troisième est
récompensé pour une comédie après isaac
de bankolé en 87 pour black mic mac et
guillaume depardieu pour les apprentis
en 96 il se joue lui-même dans ce dépôt
documentaire qui carbure au second degré
et à l'autodérision
[Musique]
mais vivre
j ai bon waouh
savage alors moi ce que j'ai envie de
dire ça va être très intelligent
j'ai envie de dire comme mon ami dany
laferrière il faut faire confiance au
temps et il faut voir le temps en temps
long et donc pour ça je remercie tous
ceux qui ont ouvert la brèche avant moi
j'ai envie de remercier deux ânes pas si
isaac de bankolé omar sy maimouna
doucouré deborah look ou moinard alice
diop gitans euros
le bon vieux colonel ladj ly et fatiha
yusuf
ça me fait plaisir de parler sans john
keane à leur égard j'ai alors j'ai envie
de dire aussi que le film tout
simplement noir avant tout part
d'humanité et on a voulu mettre de la
complexité la houle et simplificateur
viennent leur bazar et donc quand
on parle d'humanité on est en droit de
se poser la question si l'humanité de
certaines personnes n'est pas souvent
remis en cause ou si souvent elle compte
dans cette optique j'ai envie de parler
de adama traoré
j'ai envie de parler de michel est clair
et et c'est pas fini
j'ai aussi envie de dire que l'on peut
se demander si notre humanité compte
lorsqu'on voit que l' esclavage a été
retenu comme crime contre l'humanité en
2001 et que aujourd'hui sur l'espace
public
certaines personnes qui ont activement
participé au crime contre l'humanité
sont glorifiés par des statuts j'ai
aussi envie de dire que aujourd'hui
notre humanité on se pose la question si
les comptes
lorsqu'on voit aux antilles
l'utilisation du chlordécone qui est un
pesticide qui a été interdite en france
mais qu'on a continué à utiliser aux
antilles
donc je me pose vraiment la question de
savoir s'il certaine humanité compte
et je vais quitter la scène en suit
quand mon ami 30 soit non que j'adore
qui dit chaque génération doit trouver
sa mission la compo